hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a clinical chemist perspective
of the benefits and limitations of fecal
cal protectant testing
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by diasoren to learn more visit
diasoren.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the
end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
lisa johnson medical director in
clinical chemistry at arup laboratories
and an assistant professor in the
department of pathology at the
university of utah in salt lake city
lisa you may now begin your presentation
hello thanks for joining us today and so
today we're going to talk about the pros
and cons of eco cal protection testing
i have no disclosures
and so the general outline of my talk
i'm going to kind of go in the reverse
we're going to first talk about the post
analytical process so
what are the cow protection results and
how should we use them in the in for the
clinical gastroenterologists
and then i'm going to go over the
analytical considerations so what are
some of the options for the different
platforms available eliza's versus amino
assays
and then discuss the two different
extraction processes
and then last of all i'm going to talk
about a major consideration which is the
pre-analytical challenges
and that's mostly thinking about using
stool as a sample matrix for this assay
so first let's just start off with
talking about what is calprotectin
so calprotectin is a protein present in
leukocytes and it's a highly sensitive
marker of inflammation and so when the
leukocytes are activated they release
the calprotectin into the surrounding
area
and calprotectin binds to divalent metal
ions calcium magnesium and it's about to
sequester these metal ions from bacteria
and so we know that the leukocytes are
activated during this process
so when we're measuring calprotectin in
stool it's a highly sensitive marker for
intestinal inflammation
but it is not very specific because it's
just a general marker of inflammation so
cal protecting can be elevated for a
variety of different disease processes
so it's elevated in ibd and we're going
to talk about that in the next slide it
also can be elevated for certain cancers
or lesions or on invasive
gastroenteritis
and so it's not very specific for any
disease process but it helps to narrow
down for the clinician what might be
happening if there's an inflammatory
component happening in the intestine
and so for inflammatory bowel disease
ibd you might guess that cow protection
is elevated because it has an
inflammation component which is correct
so ibc is a non-infectious chronic
inflammation of the gi tract so the
immune system is overactive
activated for a variety of different
reasons
and it's attacking the gut and so
there's inflammation present
and with ibd the clinicians
put these or diagnoses into three
different categories so there's
ulcerative colitis and that affects
anywhere from the colon to the rectum
and it's more of the diffuse
inflammation of the inner mucosal layer
and then it could also be crohn's
disease and crohn's disease affects
anywhere in the entire gi tract from gum
to bomb as they like to say
and it's these discontinuous patchy
lesions that can affect a variety of the
tissue in the intestine
sometimes the clinician won't know
exactly which bucket the patient falls
in ulcerative colitis or crohn's disease
and so they might be diagnosed as
indeterminate and then the clinician
will collect more information and maybe
diagnose them later with ulcerative
colitis or crohn's disease
and for diagnosis usually what happens
is that the patient gets an endoscopic
procedure so that the gastroenterologist
can view the inflammation present
and they will collect tissues of the
intestine the biopsies
and bring the biopsies out and send them
for anatomical pathologists to view to
see if there is these characteristic
patterns of inflammation
and that's how it's diagnosed
so inflammatory bowel disease it's
not not very prevalent the problem is
about 0.4
in north america so it's pretty low but
it's a pretty serious disorder and we
want to catch it because it's chronic
and so we really need to start treating
these patients early and to get these
disease processes under control
um so
another uh scenario that looks like ibd
at least from the clinical symptoms that
is much higher that has a much higher
prevalence is irritable bowel syndrome
so here this is ibs the i stands for
something completely different irritable
bowel syndrome
and so this is a functional disorder
meaning that the gut is over or under
reactive for a variety of different
reasons
it's a clinical diagnosis so it's
diagnosed based on symptoms and it's
highly prevalent the prevalence is
estimated to be about 10 to 15 percent
maybe even higher in patients seeking a
gastroenterologist advice
and it's diagnosed by the room for
diagnostic criteria which is for current
abdominal pain at least one day per week
in the last three months associated with
at least two of the following criteria
related to defecation associated with a
stool change in frequency or in
appearance
and so a reason that this is kind of um
problematic is that you know patients go
to the gastroenterologist
they have abdominal pain they have
diarrhea
and the gastroenterologist has to kind
of quickly figure out what is affecting
that patient is it should there just um
their symptoms be treated their clinical
symptoms like in the case of ibs or do
they have some kind of inflammatory
component that requires
further treatment like inflammatory
bowel disease
and so that is one way that fecal
calprotectin can be used and so we have
these patients coming into gi clinic the
gastroenterologist can order fecal
calprotectin
if it's low that means that
inflammation is not present and that
maybe a source of their abdominal
discomfort is a non-inflammatory cause
and that's more likely in the case of
ibs
and so
the patient still should get treatment
but their symptoms need to be treated
the gastroenterologist doesn't need to
maybe do further diagnoses
for that patient
if the fecal cal protection is
borderline just mildly elevated at 50 to
120 micrograms per gram
then the clinician could think well
maybe i should retest in four to six
weeks and maybe just ask the patient
what's been going on in the recent
history
have they been taking lots of nsaids
because those can
cause some bleeding in the in the
intestinal
tract or you know did they recently have
gastroenteritis
and so the recommendation is to follow
the patient so closely and maybe retest
the cal protectant
if the fecal cal protection is elevated
that's sort of um a strong sign that
maybe this patient is having
inflammation now we don't know why
and so it's a good move for the
gastroenterologist to consider an
endoscopic procedure maybe with biopsies
to further diagnose what that patient is
having
so this is a great use for fecal cal
protection as a screening test for ibs
versus ibd
another great use for fecal cow
protection is following patients with
ibd
so inflammatory bowel disease is often a
chronic well it's usually a chronic
disease in that you know the patient has
to constantly be seen by a
gastroenterologist or followed by their
provider just to make sure that
everything is is doing okay with this
patient they often have relapse and
remitting states of inflammation
and sometimes they might require just
different modes of treatment
um so here's a study and you can see
it's quite old it's a good one from 2010
where the these authors looked at 140
patients with crohn's disease
and 40 controls and they looked at the
simple endoscopic score for crohn's
disease versus the fecal cal protection
result
so the simple endoscopic score is using
a scope and looking at the
upper intestine or the lower intestine
and measuring how much inflammation is
present
and basically how to read this graph the
higher the number the more inflammation
is present and the more severity
and you can see that there's a nice
correlation with fecal calprotectin
results and the severity of the simple
endoscopic score for crohn's disease so
this is great because the fecal cal
protection result
is much
easier to do the patient can just submit
a stool sample get a result and the
clinician and the patient have some
indication of what's going on with the
patient
and so it's a great method for following
patients with ibd
and if you can compare it to other
things that are typically used to follow
these patients so here's kind of some
metrics on sensitivity and specificity
so using calprotectin above the cutoff
for normal or maybe borderline you can
see that the sensitivity is pretty good
for picking up a flare in inflammatory
bowel disease
once again the specificity isn't so
great but that's because of all the
things that we just talked about
you know people can have inflammation
present in their gi
tract for a variety of reasons and it's
important to rule out those other
reasons
if we compare it to other serum markers
that measure inflammation
crp and the white blood cell count you
can see that they have a much lower
sensitivity in detecting those flare-ups
in patients with ibd
and then about the same specificity
and if we compare it to a clinical score
the crohn's disease activity index we
can see that that doesn't compare as
well as the lab results
and so the fecal cal protection results
because it's you know in close proximity
to the intestine it's actually one of
the best tests out there
used to follow patients with ibd
it's very helpful to put the information
in context with how the patient is
feeling
and and how they're doing with their
treatment
okay so we talked a little bit about the
clinical utility for fecal cal
protection screening for ibd versus ibs
and following patients with ibd
next let's talk about some of the
analytical considerations if for people
interested in bringing fecal cal
protection calprotectin in-house
so most fecal calprotectin assays are
some kind of amino acid format and maybe
they're an elisa and the eliza exists in
this plate format or maybe they're
kind of conjugated to this bead
and so if it's a plate format
usually that plate format is done in
batch
so it's done all at once
sometimes what can be problematic for
the batch format is that dilutions might
be have to repeat it on a second plate
so it might
cause a higher turnaround time for high
child protection results it's just
something to consider
all the steps for a manual elisa can be
accomplished manually so you don't have
to have special equipment and this is a
common method in a specialty lab and so
this is kind of a low entrance point for
laboratories thinking about bringing
this in-house
and maybe wanting to start with an elisa
format first
the other option that people can
consider for bringing in calprotectin
is the beads
and so the the amino acid is just
conjugated to the beads and the sandwich
eliza happens on the bead um and the
thing that's great about beads is that
it's random access you can pop the
specimen on the instrument and get the
results usually within 20 30 minutes
um the dilutions are performed on the
instrument so there's no waiting for the
three hour elisa to finish for the
dilution
um and the the the only sort of downfall
or maybe limitation is that it requires
the amino acid analyzer to perform that
assay for that specific vendor
and so those are just some things to
investigate if you're interested in
bringing fecal cal protectant in-house
and another thing that's important to
consider is the method of extraction so
extraction is the process of putting the
stool into some buffer and then
rigorously shaking it to extract the cow
protectant
from the stool
and so the gold standard is the manual
extraction process
and so what this
entails is that usually we do all of our
stool extractions within a hood
and so the technologist will stir the
stool because we like things well
homogenized and then we will mask out
usually about 100 migs of the stool
sample and then write down that specific
mass on that container and then dilute
it with an appropriate amount of buffer
and then that gets rigorously vortexed
and then it often has to undergo a
second dilution to be at the appropriate
concentration for the assay and it might
need a centrifugation
we're going to contrast that with the
device extraction
so the manufacturers have gotten very
creative and made many of these
extraction devices
and these are pre-filled tubes with
buffer and they have what we like to say
in my lab the magic wand
and the magic wand has these precision
grooves and these precision grooves
collects an accurate and precise amount
of stool and you can see i've i've just
shown some of the wands of different
extraction devices and just labeled how
much how many migs of stool they collect
and so it is much lower than the manual
weighing process
but the good thing about these devices
is that you know you poke it into a
homogenized dual sample stick it into
the device vortex it and then it's often
ready to go right into the assay at that
appropriate solution
so if we compare the two processes
so for manual wayne moore stool is used
and because of this it's often better
for highly heterogeneous dual samples
a manual wayne is also better for liquid
stool samples because if you can imagine
the liquid steel sample is going to drip
off the wand and that could be
problematic
the only issue with the manual wayne is
that it takes more time and effort
and if we compare that to the extraction
device
so for the extraction device less stool
is used
it's really great for more homogeneous
dual samples
and it's also a very efficient process
in extracting the stool
so within my lab we actually sort stool
samples by which extraction method they
should undergo and so if you look at the
bottom you can kind of see that i have
pictures of gravel shown
and so if there's lots of chunks in the
stool or it's highly heterogeneous then
that stool sample is going to be sorted
to one for manual wayne because we
probably need a larger stool sample to
collect the average um
average amount of what's all present to
get a more accurate cal protecting
results
whereas if you look more to the right
you can see that the gravel is more
finely and it's more
homogeneous
and so those kinds of steel samples are
more best for the device and so we sort
those into a run for the device
and we extract them in that way
how it usually pans out is we do about
sixty percent of our extractions with
the device and about forty percent of
our extractions for cal protection
through manual weighing so we actually
use both processes
because you know both are
are sort of beneficial for certain stool
samples
and one thing that labs always wonder is
is how should we monitor the entire
testing process for fecal cow protectant
and so one way that we do this in my lab
is that we have a pooled dual qc
which is exactly what it sounds like it
is cool stool that we try and target a
specific range of child protection and
it is well homogenized because we want
to use this qc sample for both manual
wayne and the device
and so we freeze a bunch of aliquots
into eppendorf tubes and every time the
lab sets up a batch of 50 samples 50
patient samples
they will include a pooled stool qc
and so this is monitoring both our
extraction process process and our
analytical process
and i've shown some data from
one of our our some of our early studies
these are the levi jennings plot for the
manual wayne and the device
and you can see that both perform very
well in sort of ensuring that this
testing process is tightly controlled
and both are about the same so as long
as the stool is homogeneous
both manners
methods of extraction work really well
it's the more heterogeneous tool samples
that we really need to focus on the
manual weighing for
um and so i would say you know perhaps
if your lab isn't running a ton of fecal
cow protection samples you don't want to
go to all this effort of making a pooled
stool qc and i totally get it because
you know it's not it it takes a little
bit for our lab to do it as well
um and so one one method that i could
see you know smaller labs doing is
finding a stool sample that is well
digested
that could be just easily homogenized
aliquoting that into eppendorf tubes
freezing it and using that as their
pooled qc extraction control throughout
the runs
and so these are just some suggestions
for how laboratories might want to
monitor their entire testing process
all right so we just went through some
of the analytical considerations
let's talk about the pre-analytical
considerations
and basically what i'm hinting at here
is that stool is just a very challenging
matrix and we we already talked about
this a little bit in the extraction
process
so in my laboratory i already told you
we sort of sort the stool types based on
if they can be done by manual wayne or
the extraction device so here are the
different bristol stool types so type
one we kind of think of as hard as rocks
my labs like to shake the container and
if it sounds like rocks they know it's
type one it should go to manual wayne
um the device can be used from types two
through six or most devices can
and so typically my lab will look at the
stool and see if if it's well
homogenized or if it's highly
heterogeneous and sort them to the
appropriate extraction method
and then type seven because
the extraction device just doesn't work
well with type seven always goes to the
manual wayne
and some issues with heterogeneous um
samples you know we're thinking of
undigested food mucus and fiber just
create problems with the cue with the
extraction device and we typically use
manual weighing
and then my lab also likes to collect
these little pill cans i think it's
pretty funny when they see these in the
stool sample and so that's that's some
entertainment for them
but there are other limitations for
stool as a matrix for quantitative
results um
mostly there's no normalization
for urine testing we often normalize to
creatinine the creatinine will give us a
hint if it's really dilute or really
concentrated and we can normalize
whatever analyte was tested in the urine
based on that there's no marker like
that for stool testing
and the water content varies so stool is
mostly water about 65 to 75 percent of
water
in the different bristol stool types
another interesting study found that the
average within subject coefficient of
variation is somewhere between 30 to 40
percent so what this means is that if a
healthy individual submits a stool
sample one day and then the next day
submits another stool sample
on average that cal potential result
will vary within 30 to 40 percent
and so this study estimated that a
reference change value would be about
100
to 130 percent
so what that means is that if a patient
submits a stool sample and it's 50
micrograms per gram
later on if they submit a second stool
sample you wouldn't consider the cal
protection result significantly
different unless it was at least 100
micrograms per gram so you need to see a
pretty big change in the calprotectin
results to see that it's significantly
different because of all this
variability
so that's kind of wrapping up my talk
just to kind of review the learning
objectives
so we talked about the pros and cons of
the quantitative measurements in stool
we discussed the extraction process and
i showed you some examples of using a
pooled stool qc to monitor the entire
testing process
and then we also discussed the best
ordering practices
or the clinical utility of fecal cal
protection testing that maximizes the
benefits for patients
so i'd like to thank csorn for
sponsoring this presentation with lab
roots and last of all i'd also like to
thank my lab for all the wonderful work
that they do and i think they do an
excellent job
and with that i'd like to also thank you
for your attention and i'm happy to
answer any questions
well thank you lisa for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is can you summarize
the challenges and benefits for labs
wanting to bring fecal cal protectant
in-house
sure
i'd say that we've steadily seen a
growth in this assay over time
um and we also know that patients with
inflammatory bowel disease need to be
followed pretty closely by the
clinicians and so
usually in your local area area there
will be like an ibd clinic and and often
these patients are sending in samples
and so i think you know it benefits the
labs to bring this in-house because it's
a faster turnaround time to get the
results to the clinician
um and uh you know it's it's certainly
uh
of need because you know the volumes
probably are increasing steadily over
time
um some of the challenges you know for a
clinical chemistry lab
it's probably working with stool um but
you know the expertise probably exists
in your infectious disease laboratories
or your microbiology laboratories
and so it could be something that's done
in conjunction with those labs to kind
of work out the process and find
something that that suits them
great thank you
our next question
is there a liquid stool protocol or do
you always have to use the way method
for bristol 7 stool samples
yes um so with
um with my laboratory we use the whey
method
for the liquid stool samples because we
actually just use a transfer pipet and
we transfer some of the liquid sample
into a container that can be weighed on
the analytical balance and then we do
the certain dilutions
right now many of the package inserts
have a different process
where you can
pipette out a certain amount with a
pipette
right into the extraction device
my laboratories did test this but
because we
sort of sort the run specifically based
right now on the manual wayne and cue
set
we were getting used to our current
workflow and we really like it and so we
couldn't figure out how which which
bucket to put these liquid stool samples
in if we're doing a separate extraction
process from the two that we're already
doing
but i would say you know labs that have
more flexibility
in their workflow could probably figure
out how to do this with the pipette
method and it likely works
thank you
next question
what are if any concerns of false
positives or false negatives with this
assay
um
i mean so with false positives and false
negatives you're thinking more of like
what's happening in stool
um and so you know because it's an
immunoassay and it's measuring the
protein i don't know that we've really
seen any false positives or false
negatives but it's more thinking what's
happening to the patient you know this
fecal cal protecting could be increased
because maybe the patient is receiving
cancer treatment and they're having some
kind of intestinal inflammation
in that sense or potentially maybe fecal
calprotectin isn't increased because
maybe it's a slow amount of inflammation
higher in the upper or in the small
intestine and maybe the it's just too
dilute by the time it it comes out in
stool um and so it's important to think
about the clinical indications and why
this result might vary a little bit in
what would be expected
thank you
next question
the threshold is 50 but do i properly
understand that the variation is high
and the result can be 100 with another
extraction
um i mean so the the manufacturers set
the threshold for normal
when you repeatedly measure a stool
sample you will see some variation
within that stool sample
and that's your analytical variation
so what i was mentioning previously was
the reference change value the variation
within a patient
and so i would say that you know
laboratories have to set the
expectations for their analytical
variation um and a hundred would be
quite high because that's you know
that's quite a bit more stool to get
that result um and so i i think that
that's that's a little bit elevated
and it would be important to do studies
to kind of see what variation you would
expect
for your analytical side
thank
you it looks like we have time for one
more question
do you see fc testing volumes increasing
or decreasing in the future
this testing is actually steadily
increasing
you know the gastroenterologists really
like to get this result they
they find it very useful to know if the
patient has inflammation present in the
intestine because this kind of helps
them in their in their diagnostic
workups um and so we've seen this
steadily increasing um additionally you
know patients with inflammatory bowel
disease are learning how to read this
result and how to kind of follow their
disease process
and so that's very helpful for them to
make sure that their disease stays under
control
well thank you lisa do you have any
final comments for our audience
uh thank you all for attending and i'm
happy to answer any other questions that
you have so thank you
great well thank you again lisa for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor diasoren for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye